Israeli Prime Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu has vowed to annex Jewish
settlements in the occupied West Bank
if reelected next week the statement he
made in an interview with an Israeli
television channel marks a policy
turnaround Netanyahu has promoted Jewish
settlement expansion in his four terms
as Prime Minister but until now he's
refrained from presenting plans for the
future of the West Bank settlements
which are widely considered illegal
under international law palestinian
officials denounced Netanyahu's campaign
pledge saying he would face a real
problem if he followed through we have
been in the same position for the last
you know 51 years since 67 and we think
that you know our resilience our cease
fastness to stay in the land is the best
way to defend our own interests you know
he cannot expel us because we are not
going to accept be expelled we will stay
there we will resist you know such
behavior such decision and then you know
the international community has to deal
with us you know in that respect for
more on that let's cross over to our
correspondent Tanya Kramer in Jerusalem
Tanya thanks for joining us how
seriously are Palestinians taking this
threat I think there's a lot of concern
which has hurt the Palestinian official
talking there there's especially concern
because of the recent US recognition of
the Golan Heights and there's concern
that this might have set a precedent
actually because also the occupied West
Bank has been captured in the 1967 war
and Palestinian officials have said
they're feeling that that might have set
a precedent also to annex this territory
now annexation talk is nothing really
new in Israeli politics at least some of
the smaller parties that are part of the
government coalition in the outgoing
government right now we have elections
in two days here they have always pushed
for annexation at least for parts of the
West Bank or at least for the
so-called area see where most of the
settlements are and they have said you
know that they have made a lot of
pressure Netanyahu to annex this
territory now the Palestinians are very
much concerned that all of this together
might set you know the atmosphere also
seeing that there was a very muted
international reaction there has been a
lot of criticism but it was a muted
reaction more or less that you know they
might go ahead with their with these
plans you know just just days before the
general election I have to assume there
are some people who might view this as a
blatant appeal to amass non-arab votes
is Netanyahu feeling pressure well this
is certainly welling cry out which to
his most nationalist base and he wants
to tell his voters to go out and vote
for Likud or reaching out to those
voters who are thinking about voting for
the smaller some of the smaller
right-wing and ultra nationalist parties
there are a lot of them wanting as seats
in the Knesset and some of them might
not come over at the election special so
every vote to those parties might be a
lost vote for Netanyahu but he's also
under pressure because there has been a
tight race between the Likud his party
and the newly formed blue-and-white
party by the former army achieved penny
guns and pulses predict a neck-to-neck a
race having said that in Israeli
politics it's all about being able to
form a coalition and he opposes again
predict and we have to take those polls
of course with the grain of soul they're
not always that accurate but that
Netanyahu has much more chances to find
partners and to form a coalition within
his right wing bloc than a mr. guns now
having said that these are the parties
the smaller right wing ultra nationalist
parties that have a Pro annexation
agenda and they might actually ask him
for Christ to turn his coalition ask him
to follow up on this election Platt
Tanya Kramer in Jerusalem for DW thanks
so much for joining us
you